you're very young fellow and you've had  a lot of success early I'm just just  getting used to the fame thing cuz  you've been doing this for a couple of  years now on the Goldbergs yeah this is  the fourth season for season  yeah I think what was it like when you  were you know a kid I mean you're still  a kid but you're a really a kid and  you're just starting this show and  you're seeing your face on Billboard's  was that strange for you  oh it just it was it's just the weirdest  thing yeah cuz your face is just really  big and this one time on the news I was  watching I I forget what she knows  Channel that's okay no one cares what's  news yeah I knew you were watching a  News Channel News Channel yeah and I  this bus they were like showing this bus  that hit a dog mm-hmm and on the side of  the bus was my face it was the strangest  feeling and I felt responsible for well  the dogs dead and then there's this guy  oh I'm sorry  you